all right Riley brother where you from
originally where he grew up I was born
in Renton Washington about 20 minutes
outside of Seattle okay tell me about
your family
my family my mom was divorced once and
then remarried - my dad had two step
siblings a brother and a sister and a
full sister I'm the youngest of all of
them and how was your childhood mm-hmm
my childhood was like very similar to
everyone else's my parents tried they
put me in sports the one thing for me is
like I wasn't allowed to have friends
over I didn't have a like a normal
childhood in that aspect I didn't have
many friends live down the woods didn't
see a lot of people there wasn't a huge
like population in my hometown or at my
high school but I spent a lot of time
with probably my sister and one of my
really good friends and playing sports
so pretty pretty nice children except
for little isolation um as I got older
eight nine ten
closer to my teens I started to realize
my dad was what did I now know as an
alcoholic and it was getting really bad
at that time well he wasn't around as
much
he was only around if it was to force me
to play some kind of sport that he
wanted me to play or control me and
whatever he wanted to do and so it's
kind of weird in that in that aspect any
abuse er like that yeah well of course
yeah like I said I wasn't allowed to
have friends over didn't understand that
so I asked him why like 10
my mom my mom would be like it's just
your dad's rule so one time I was like
hey like why am I not allowed to have
friends over and he just don't ask me
again why you know how to have people
over I don't like my stuff being stolen
or I don't like to have to watch out for
the one of you I would have to look
after to you and I asked him again any
[ __ ] he hit me and he said shut up
don't ask me again and said I didn't ask
him again [ __ ] like that yeah he would I
was physically mostly verbally abused if
I am and you you left home at what age
as soon as I could at 18 hey where'd you
go I will I moved in to my buddy Conners
house my buddy Connor
went to high school together me and a
couple other friends we moved in with
him after his dad was hit and killed by
a inebriated driver from our school
actually it was pretty crazy it's crazy
and then drugs getting the picture for
you oh but then right there right then
it was just you know party and weed fun
parties up until I graduated actually
welcome back on that graduation day I
I'd gotten pretty [ __ ] up drunk pretty
drunk and took some pills that day and
with everyone from graduation like
that's not normal not everyone did that
I was not now June graduation of course
I'd smoke weed and I was hoping my
parents wouldn't notice
that's not normal you know and so 1819
is when that start I started with pills
I was always able to set pills down
though and I watched my buddy Connor who
I'm again with that was the first time I
realized that there was a thing called
withdrawal
this is the first time I was shown what
that was was because he was wrong and he
was like
I can't do this anymore he sat what
you're all done it's on his couch smoke
weed and went through a week at hell by
himself and he's like like I really
don't want to touch that [ __ ] again then
if that's what it goes it's crazy so
where did the drug situation go from
there for you so
I once I turned 19 I started
experimenting with a lot of drugs made a
really good friend his name was Noah
moved from Florida we all know Florida's
not the best place a lot of people there
have been to rehab many times there's a
lot of rehab there there's a lot of
different drugs there so I started
experimenting with pretty much every
single drug there is I got back into
doing a little bit of pills percocets
and one day we were looking for him and
he was like just can't find him man I
just can't find I mean I couldn't find
him either and I was like [ __ ] and that
sucks
he was like but I do know where to find
like heroin and I was like what's that
and he was like it's a lot better in
pills I think you'll like it and I was
like god we might as well like how much
is it he was like 10 bucks and I was
like what we've been spending 30-man
good let's go get it mmm we picked it up
and I remember I took two or three it's
a bit off of a foil and I was at the
doughnut shop in Maple Valley and I
really fell asleep or I nodded out for
3-4 hours and I remember after the first
hit man it was like this is what I was
waiting for my whole life this is I feel
[ __ ] right I feel like I fit in like
this is what I've been looking for
anywhere that long yeah yeah I knew I
was [ __ ] I knew it and like I knew it
I was like this isn't good but like I'm
willing to let everything go for this
drug right now I knew him I knew she was
gonna go south from there so I was 19
yeah I told you - today I'm 26 I turned
26 last week I says have you been using
ever since well
no I mean I've had periods of sobriety
briefly the most I've ever had was seven
months how'd you do that Lord I'm not
sure obviously working a program going
to meetings having a sponsor you know
what I mean
the cliche stuff works I had a kid on
the way
and my baby's mom we just recently broke
up three months ago or so she was clean
at the time as well and I thought it was
time to buckle down then and like ice it
wasn't enough you know and so that's how
I did that then treatment initially
program and fellowship kept me clean but
the depression and the band the bipolar
that I also have it's been hard I don't
know it's hard I can't seem to maintain
any type of positive sobriety and it's
I've been to some [ __ ] bad places
because of this you know what I mean
yeah place I never thought I would go
coming from just a little rural town
called Ravensdale Washington being a
little country boy
wheeling with my friends every day to
full-blown heroin addict in [ __ ] la
just get rough this is the worst part of
it it's so easy to score here though
it's just easy for me you know I mean
what do you do for money no lately it's
been
who has access to it these baby I don't
exactly want to say me about 200 guys
will do boosting stupid I know I don't
steal necessarily I might partake in
fraudulent things you're you're ready to
get into debt and financially sometimes
I'm doing really well but when I'm not
I'm really not I have nothing and it's
really hard for me to make any money
yeah there's always like recycling if
I'm really [ __ ] low I need to do
something just to make a couple bucks
but normally people have my back I mean
they're one step ahead and have
financial means and ways usually
fraudulently and I used to steal can't
do it anymore
I would steal from my family still for
my girlfriends still for myself
stores stupid yeah what do you think
most people don't realize about
addiction
biggest one for me
my baby's mom's family has a huge
resentment and they're like how can you
do all these things I've stolen from
them you know what I mean
and I've done some pretty poor things to
my baby's mom or rather I've done things
that I'm not proud of and she didn't
like and her family knows you know and I
mean it they're like how can you do that
you know I just I I tell them that I
literally do not recognize myself or
that person that made those actions
because I feel like I wouldn't do them
it's not who I really am and what people
don't realize about addiction is that if
I don't have a means to get well or my
drug there's nothing that's gonna stop
that that part of me that [ __ ] needs
that drug because it comes before
everything it doesn't matter it will
come before my son my family my my I
well-being water food sleep sex anything
yeah some someone told me recently it
becomes more important than survival
exactly that is it that is survival and
that's how an addicts brain works and
it's just [ __ ] that's why when
commenters on my channel will say oh you
just gotta go to rehab and stop it's
like you probably have as much as we're
more common sense than all the common
sense that's being commented but it's
not about common sense it's really sad
it's sad that people think it's a choice
or addition oh they're just like oh it's
sad they can't get their lives together
well man had said that you're [ __ ]
even commenting on that and not helping
that person because if you were in that
position would you not want help yeah
it's something like 90% of addicts don't
get help
I think it's 99% of addicts don't get
help and even though I've received help
it's never been enough for me to
continue and keep a healthy life like
I've been in up in and out of treatment
15 times
and hopefully 16 today because I really
want to go to treatment today and and
we're trying to set that up which is
weird that this happened but I've been
in and out 16 times and it's been the
[ __ ] hardest thing I've ever had to
do people don't understand that how
[ __ ] hard this [ __ ] is man yeah and
no matter what my outside circumstances
are I had like I have a son baby mama
just got clean with me [ __ ] four
months ago she broke up with me and has
a new boyfriend like she's clean that's
awesome
my son not gonna be enough to keep me
clean like just because I have that
responsibility and just because I want
to doesn't mean like I'm gonna it's
[ __ ] up that's [ __ ] it's sad
that's a curse that you can't shake you
think I can't man I just I don't I gotta
find something that works
you know hey did your do you think it's
perhaps just your version of your dad's
alcoholism that you're experiencing no I
I mean I believe I'm an alcoholic too
and I'll go okay
[Music]
I do believe did your dad ever get clean
no I do believe the way he raised me was
not very it wasn't a good start to life
and now I should treat people he didn't
treat me very he didn't give me like
good values he didn't show me [ __ ]
unless I [ __ ] up and he showed me that
I [ __ ] up you know I do believe a lot
of the negative traits he has like
narcissism and whatever just being a man
and an [ __ ] and [ __ ] what is it
when you say don't do something and then
you go do it no a hypocrite yeah you
know and he hates liars I grew up with a
dad that hated liars and [ __ ] I turned
into a liar
quick ever since I was young like like
six or seven and then it turned into a
habitual lie with my last with my baby's
mom and I was in a fantasy world of Lies
and she knew that and one day I got
clean with her before I came out to
California five months ago and told her
everything she didn't know about
anything she was like I know I go what
what do you mean you know she does I
know
I've told you every time that I've asked
you about these things and I was like
are you telling me like I've been lying
to myself for about seven months huh
she's like yeah you've been living in
some kind of fantasy world lying to
yourself lying to me
and believing those lives nobody else
has and I was just it was crazy you know
that I didn't think I was as bad as
anybody else in this thing just coming
from treatment like you see other people
I didn't think it was just bad gone as
far I wasn't a denial still I have a
problem right but I was man I had a
problem with bipolar and I didn't I
didn't understand that I used people
places and things to make me feel better
and it went in cycles and I would lie to
myself that everyone else believed in my
lies
it is horrible and you know I lost a
great relationship and my son yeah to
CPS and then we're fighting for custody
back right now
so it was a bummer to have her leave you
know but sorry okay you're still young
yet yeah you you have a long future
ahead of you that you can straighten out
but it I'm not saying it's easy no it's
not but now I'm in a position where I'm
alone and I'm forced to look at me I
just got a [ __ ]
do it one more time you know what I mean
so I gotta do it let's just [ __ ] do
it one more time
give it everything I have because I
don't want to live out here homeless you
know I mean people may think that my
kids it's a choice you know its source
and I don't like it out here oh it's
just hard you know it's not a horrible
way to live yeah I mean I'd rather be
back in Washington with my babies mom
mm-hmm
not um single huh with a child you know
that I can't see now and owning our
house I don't want to live on the street
away from those things
mm-hmm but that's how I hard this [ __ ]
is you know that's crazy all right Riley
thank you so much for sharing your story
mmm you're welcome good luck thank you
you